[Music]
all right let's go out to
Omaha somewhere in Middle America uh
talk to James what's up
James hey how we doing Dr John we're
rocking it on to the break of dawn
what's up with you not a whole lot
appreciate you for the opportunity today
kind of speak with you of course man
what's up so kind of a two-part question
uh a little bit multifaceted but first
off um how would do you suggest people
um myself being the husband validate my
wife's concerns about my mom but also
trying to somewhat back my mom as
well oh man kind of kind of tough
basically you're like Hey how do we
create civilization on
Mars yeah and get there right
um you're asking a very impossible
possible task um what did your mom do
that your wife doesn't like or what is
your mom's doing that your wife doesn't
like that you're that you're quietly
secretly thinking I think my mom's right
what is it yep yep so a couple instances
that have happened in the last probably
six months uh the first one was she you
know my family didn't give my wife like
a birthday card or even a birthday
present other than just like a simple
text while you know her family is like
showering me on my birthday and so she
kind of sees like the comparison
situation there okay that's how it
started that's how I initially felt her
feelings supp it but then now it's more
of like a I'm a I'm one of four kids and
we're the only ones that don't have kids
in our family or for our immediate
family and everybody else in my siblings
do so she sees the favoritism of the
grand kids and their families but we
kind of get left third or fourth fiddle
well yeah because they have grandkids
correct and that's that's how I I I see
it that way but how long have youall
been
married uh about a year and a half okay
there we go yep
um so she's not on the phone to defend
herself if she was calling me saying the
same things just from her
perspective I would tell her as quick as
humanly possible stop the comparison
game and start the communication game
here's what I mean by that hey James my
family goes over the toop with birthdays
mad
house your family um sprinkles some
shredded cheese over nachos for
Thanksgiving I want to have a lot of
love on my birthday
now you have an opportunity to help meet
her
needs yep right the other side of it is
you know your family and after your
birthday when you got showered with a
ton of stuff you knew your parents would
never do that correct and
so you can facilitate Mom Dad birthdays
are a huge deal to my
wife send some stuff
M send a singing telegram and your
parents be like that's stupid we're not
doing that and say yes you are you're
doing
that and then you can
facilitate that's fair see what I'm
saying yeah absolutely but it all comes
down to is as long as your wife is
keeping score she's just gonna have a
miserable life does she do this on other
things too like how much your friends
make and who's driving what car and how
big their house is and what their
laundry room looks like uh no not NE
necessarily like materialistic things
the only that's why it kind of threw me
off with the birthday thing um because
she didn't seem like that would bother
her but I think it was you know she
wants to have this really great
relationship with my mom and there's
been a lot of things that have happened
in the last about year with my family
you know her parents have my mom's
parents both passed away within six
months of each other um and then you
know my sister is going to a husband
who's an alcoholic and then my brother
just got a divorce so it was kind of
like everything unraveled all at once
and my wife is sitting here like well we
haven't done anything wrong why can't we
continue to kind of work on a
relationship since she sees me having a
great relationship with her mom that
makes sense or her Dad
too gosh can I be a kind of a prick for
a second yeah
absolutely like what is it about like
watching your mom drown that your wife
sees that and she's like what about
me like that seems super not attune to
reality yeah and I and I could be just
it could be the way I'm I'm phrasing it
but I like I have a rule I don't like
talking about people's wives but this is
a
show like I don't know what about that
situation six months where two of your
brothers and and two of your mom's kids
that's going through hell she just lost
both of her parents
and your wife isn't there she wants to
build a relationship she's not there on
the front porch doing everything she can
to walk alongside your mom while her
whole world falls apart yeah but instead
she's sitting at home being like why
doesn't she call
me yeah and I and I think too um that
seems super immature man yeah I I think
I think also you know the the extra part
that I haven't quite detailed is you
know like my wife has been the first
person to go help my sister watch the
kids while she's going to visit um her
husband and the rehab facility or we you
know my family me and my wife seem to be
the first people to always offer up our
help and want to be those people at the
Forefront of helping okay and I feel
like she just doesn't know if it's like
my family doesn't know how to
reciprocate that in the sense of like
just you know for example a little
acknowledgement on your birthday more
than a text but I guess it's kind of
like we keep giving giving giving and
we're obviously doing it for the right
reasons but it just seems like she
doesn't feel that type of love that I
think she wants to H you know in the
source that she wants to have it in you
know like you're Love Languages and such
yeah I mean it it sounds like um okay so
she's not selfish she sounds like she's
very giving and very kind thank you for
claring that clarifying that yeah
um
I mean it I would be willing to bet
money this is about
communication yes meaning if she sat
with your mom and said I love you so
much and I want you to be a part of my
birthday party next
year that few things in the world would
make your mom smile more than that yeah
and just teaching somebody else in a
different family system here's how I
like to be
loved because for many a text message is
like a cold drink of water in the desert
oh my gosh they
remembered yep right yep yep and you've
probably had a few birthdays where you
got a text message the next day and
they're like oh sorry we got busy hope
you had a great birthday and then for
you let's just help my folks
roll and for your wife that would be the
end of time if her parents forgot right
yeah and I and I think the root of it is
too you know like growing up completely
different lives you know they had her
parents that were um you know when they
had kids they were you know well off had
great jobs and they only had two of them
whereas my family started young they had
four kids so we you know I lived off
handy downs I'm the youngest whereas
she's never had one because she has a
brother and just her so right I I would
be very careful about doing things early
on in a marriage to try to get somebody
in the new family to like
you because what you end up doing is
treating them like a
401k I'm doing these nice things as an
investment so that you will like me and
I will have this magical fantasy life
that I want to
have yeah versus there's a need I'm
going to show
up yeah and over time if people are ugly
they don't care that I'm there it's not
reciprocated then yeah I'm going to put
my energy somewhere else that's
fine but my guess is with your mom's
life on on
fire the lack of attention may
be such a gift to your mom cuz she
can
yeah yeah and I think too the fact that
we aren't also causing issues is a
relief at the moment too not we causing
issues but you know there's there's
things that have just been imploded on
their on on them and then we're over
here just kind of being successful
couple and just kind of trying to help
out as much as we possibly can but right
and y'all are a year and a half in make
no mistake your tough days are ahead
they'll come yep and it looks like your
mom and dad are the kind of folks who
circle the wagons and take care of their
kids and love their kids and work walk
through hell with them absolutely and
right
now y'all aren't in that y'all aren't in
the storm man yeah
yep so here here's what I would CH
here's my Challenge and it's a talk
tough one um I don't think you have to
Plate mom plate wife I don't think you
have to do any of that stuff I think
it's as clear as hey honey my mom shows
Love
by being a writer
die when things get off the rails my mom
will be
there and because there's four kids
they've been running around trying to
figure out what up from down for the
last 25 years um my mom just that's just
not how she does it and she would if she
knew so I'm G to tell
her hey Mom Dad birthdays are a
humongous deal to my wife and we'd love
to invite you into it next
time yeah and maybe even you take a knee
on this one and say honey I should have
told my mom how big of a deal these kind
of things are how big of a deal
Thanksgiving is how big of a deal
Christmas is here's here's like my house
okay I'll I'll give you a good example
we first got married um my wife came
over to our house for Easter so here's
like a picture of Easter and I'm kind of
over dramatizing but not
really my dad would get a bag of those
um individually wrapped candy covered
marshmallows they're eggs they're so
good I like to put 14 of them in my
mouth all at once and rub them on my
body okay they're incredible and he
would say everybody turn around and we'd
all turn around he'd stand at the front
yard and throw them into the front
yard just from the front porch and he'd
go look kids Easter money came we all
run out and grab
them and then Easter was like over that
was it now I did have some Easter egg
hunt as a kid I'm over dramatizing it
right but that's basically what it was
for my wife Easter families came from
States
over yep everybody came out to the dairy
farm was a huge thing so her first
Easter with me and my family was
devastating MH because Easter was every
it was the most important holiday for
her and her family and for me and my
family it was a it was a way to get
pre-diabetic right and so here's what my
wife did that was so so incredible she
said hey Easter is a humongous deal to
me if this is how y'all celebrate Easter
awesome good for your family I want to
do it celebrate Easter with my family
and I was like great sounds awesome
and so Easter became when we went out to
her family's place in these different
different parts of the country it was a
it but it started with
communication yeah right and then we
figured it out and I could have said I'm
not doing that I like how my family does
I like us all just sitting on the couch
nobody talking and us just mainlining
sugar and red number
40 but I didn't because I love my wife
right you see what I'm saying so it was
about communication and expectation and
dude it's been magic ever since and so I
think it sounds sound like that's where
you're at
and I would have no
problem if your wife says gosh I wish
your mom would care more about us I and
and I would have no problem saying it
looks like my mom is up to her eyeballs
in care right
now she's really blessed to have at
least a couple of her kids in her Circle
acting like um adults or being well or
not dealing with some sort of crisis and
she's really lucky that she's got people
in her family that love each other and
look out for each other like you guys do
we're going to go take care of the kids
we're going to go do X Y and Z that's
awesome it's a it's
amazing but I would also steer clear of
D we're not going to do any comparisons
of course they've got grandkids man like
that's just the way that's going to be
they're going to focus their energy over
there and I don't have I mean there's no
heartbreak over there y'all can choose
to go over there and be a part of those
conversations or you can sit at home
with your arms folded and be like why
aren't they coming over here well you
don't have any kids you don't have any
grandkids and grandkids are fun and cute
and Goofy everybody just s they're like
they just look at them and they roll
around on the floor or whatever they do
and everyone goes ah and then they poop
and then they eat and they go to bed
repeat right that's just it that's it
and so all I have to say is I would get
my feelings ready that's just not the
stage y are in yet it's
not at the end of the day choosing to
look around and be like Why Not Me Why
Not Me Why Not Me is a recipe it's a
choice to be more miserable in the
present I'm going to continue to do the
next right thing the think I think the
thing I think is ethical the thing I
think is aligned with my values I'm not
going to do the comparison stuff and I'm
going to continue to seek joy and Beauty
in my life not seek places where it's
not fair and I know that continual
service and continual avoidance gets
taxing and and tiring after a while then
I get to take my elsewhere if that's
what I choose to
do but it sounds like just some good
oldfashioned hey we're Newly Weds we're
still figuring this out I'll take it for
the for my family we didn't Community we
don't do birthdays that well but next
year is going to be off the rails and
it's not because we don't love you it's
just how we do it and we're going to do
it differently this time start that
communication now man your marriage is
going to be something very very special
as you
go